[Music]  this is mozart  and we are oh come on  what's their valta they're literally  getting taken to like the kind of  locations you get to do hitman missions  on they won't let us go to iceland  yeah for one week  bro these retards got to go to malta i  don't get to go to malta  welcome to malta 47  [Laughter]  there's a dutch diplomat who is in town  right now visiting some bankers  it's up to you to ensure that that  meeting does not happen  [Laughter]  oh man i wanted i wanted a [ __ ]  agency i want a whole game  [ __ ] hit man  [Laughter]  can we  can we redo a certain point in that game  and just have merch through the  voiceover  welcome to malta 47.  there's a dutch diplomat who is in town  right now visiting some bankers  it's up to you to ensure that that  meeting does not happen